president-elect biden preparing to move
into the white house president trump is
packing up for his permanent move to
florida
moving truck moving trucks were spotted
outside mr trump's mar-a-lago resort in
palm beach yesterday
manuel bajorka spoke to people in palm
beach where there is mixed reaction to
their new neighbor manuel good morning
good morning mar-a-lago is just across
the water from us here and even before
he was president it has been a lightning
rod of controversy between mr trump
and some of his uber wealthy neighbors
that will not change
come wednesday when president trump
returns to palm beach
annie marie delgado plans to be front
and center at the airport
she was the head of trump team 2020 a
statewide group of trump loyalists
it's going to be massive massive there
are so many people going to come
and they're going to welcome this
president home and it's going to be
peaceful and it's going to be exciting
but not everyone shares that enthusiasm
says christine stapleton
a senior political reporter at the palm
beach post west palm beach where we are
right now
is extremely democratic stapleton says
mr trump's popularity in town
is fragile since the capital riots
there's been a real shift in whether or
not mar-a-lago will continue to be a
venue
that gop and conservative groups
want to have their events there they may
not want to
according to the palm beach post one
fundraising event in 2020 at mar-a-lago
brought in an estimated
25 million dollars mr trump will
reportedly move into mar-a-lago
he purchased the property in 1985 and
turned it into a private club
for the past four years it's been his
winter home away from home
but can it be his permanent home
neighbors of mar-a-lago recently sent a
letter to town leaders
citing a 1993 agreement they say
prohibits anyone from living permanently
on the property
because it's a social club democrat dave
ehrenberg
is state attorney for palm beach county
is this a political issue yet another
one
whether he should live here or not i
think trump's defense will be that this
is political
he may say in court that the town and
everyone knew that he was living there
and never sought to enforce this
agreement until now when they started
to disagree with his politics politics
aside ehrenberg points out that people
in palm beach
simply like their privacy even his
supporters on palm beach and there are
many supporters on the island but even
they don't want the drama the commotion
that president trump will bring to the
island because that's why they move
there they like their privacy they like
their quiet
and this will disrupt a lot of things on
the island do you think that
uh south florida is now kind of the
heart of the gop
given that the former president will be
living here
well now now now now brown cow you said
the bad word in my book
gop oh okay i'm a trump league
we absolutely
have to do some some serious cleanup
work
within the republican party gop quote
unquote especially in the state of
florida
still plenty of supporters there as you
can see the post reporter christine
stapleton points out that mr trump owns
three other homes on the island he can
live in
and she does not believe the legal
arguments against him living at
mar-a-lago
will stick the president's children don
jr and ivanka are also reportedly eyeing
moves to south florida
ivanka and her husband jared kushner are
said to have purchased property near
miami
tony very interesting manny and we all
at the table here learned a new word
trumplikin yeah we didn't know it thank
you very much the fact that a republican
would say that a republican is a bad
word
yeah and she said it very proudly too
his power in the party still exactly
right